فرضته فيفا على الملاعب العراقيه في نهايه
عام 2019 بسبب سوء الواقع الامني تعود
البصره لاحتضان بطوله الخليج بدورتها
الخامسه والعشرين ولم يخلو الحدث من الجدل
فدعونا نرى ما حصل
فنانون عراقيون رفضوا دعوه الاتحاد
العراقي لكره القدم ووزاره الشباب
والرياضه افتتاح حفل البطوله منهم الفنان
كاظم الساهر الذي لم يعلن عن اسباب رفضه
والفنان ماجد المهندس الذي اكد التزامه
بحفل اخر من الصعب تاجيله الامر الذي لاقى
عتبا كبيرا من قبل جمهورهما كما سنرى
في الشعب كله الدول العربيه
طلعت من العراق وبدات بالعراق والعراق هو
وصلك مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي هنالك جدلون
اخر ورفض يقابله تشجيع جمهور الخليج يجد
ان العراق والبصره على وجه الخصوص لا تزال
بيئه ملغمه بالمخاطر بينما يشجع رياضيون
وشخصيات عامه خليجيه واخرى عراقيه لاقامه
الحدث وحضوره في مدينه الفيحاء
[موسيقى]
ستكون هذه المره الثانيه التي يستضيف فيها
العراق بطوله الخليج بعد ان اقيمت الاولى
في بغداد عام
1979 وتوجد فيها العراق بطلا انذاك اما
اليوم فتتعهد الجهات المنظمه والجمهور
العراقي بان تكون هذه الدوره مميزه جدا
وتبقى عالقه في ذاكرتي كل من حضرها زينب
المشاط صباح العربيه بغداد